champetier composteur l'art de montrer
ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur du
compost ce n'est pas une exposition mais
du recyclage deux champignons un grand
et un petit installé depuis octobre 2012
sur 3 ha du potager du roi à versailles
création du paysagiste claude pasquier
ils servent au compostage des déchets du
potager une forme spécialement choisis
par le paysagiste pour mettre en valeur
le travail des bactéries et des
champignons qui certes au compostage à
la fois beau et utile du compost produit
havas d'épluchures de carottes pommes de
terre de la paille et d'haricots malade
il faut un bon équilibre entre les
éléments carbonées les éléments azotés
si vous avez trop de carbone trop de
matière sèche ça va pas faire grand
chose parce que les bactéries et les
champignons vont pas trouver
leur nourriture nécessaire si vous avez
trou trop d'azoté trop de matière verte
trop de matière on va dire riche en
acides aminés en protéines on aura
plutôt tendance à avoir un compost qui
va pourrir plutôt que de se transformer
en terrain ça se fait on va dire à la
fois l'oeil on va dire 1/3 2/3 mais ça
se fait aussi on va dire par expérience
une expérience et un équilibre qui
permet de ne pas se tromper sur les
aliments à mettre dans le compost la
matière animale est interdite pour ne
pas attirer les rongeurs non recyclables
le bois brut et le métal sont aussi
prohibé pour que le terreau se forment
et que le compost ne pourrissent pas la
matière riche comme la pomme de terre
doit être éliminé dans le champignon de
claude pasquier un terreau qui se
forment plus rapidement en été grâce à
une meilleure température comme pour
nous on est plus facilement actif quand
il fait chaud quand il fait froid
les microorganismes sont plus actifs
quand il fait chaud quand il fait froid
pour les passionnés d'art et de compost
il est possible d'acquérir le champignon
de claude pasquier